so a couple of months ago we talked
about the overwhelming number of cases
of sexual misconduct in the competitive
smash community
and in case you don't remember there
were over 100 people accused of sexual
misconduct
ranging from allegations of sexual
harassment to allegations of outright
sexual assault
for the most part the people accused
have either apologized left the scene or
otherwise gone dark but the story isn't
over yet
nairo one of the biggest names in a
smash scene broke his silence recently
to refute the allegations made against
him
and it got me thinking what's next for
smash
where do we go from here
alright so a quick recap back in july
amidst
allegations of sexual misconduct from
all parts of the gaming and streaming
communities
the competitive smash scene was put
under a bit of a microscope
there were over 100 allegations of
sexual misconduct directed at members of
the smash community
the accused ranged from smaller names to
some of the biggest personalities in the
scene
zero was considered one of the best
smash players of all time was accused of
sending sexually explicit messages to a
minor
d1 a commentator on some of smash's most
iconic plays was
accused of rape and senpai who
commentated evo
was accused of having a sexual
relationship with a minor many of the
bigger names have either apologized
left the scene or both some people have
sought entry back into the community
but for the most part they've been
rejected or just gone dark
but a few weeks ago one of the biggest
names who was accused broke their
silence
they were feuding the allegations made
against them and they're also saying
that
their alleged victim was their abuser
okay so
let's go way back to july again on july
2nd 2020
zack captain zach lauth alleged that he
had oral sex with nairo nairobi quezada
when zach was 15 and nairo was 20. zack
also accused nairo of paying him hush
money to keep the saw a secret
now at the time there were some
questions about zack's credibility given
he was still serving out a ban for
blackmailing elliot ally bastian carosa
oyarse who
zach was in a relationship with when
zach was 16 and ally was 26.
but following zack's allegations nairo
apologized and pretty much went dark on
all of social media
his twitch account has since been
unpartnered and banned his team energy
esports dropped him
and while his twitter remains up it's
pretty much inactive in the months
following the allegations another
pro-smash player tamim tamim omari
formerly known as mistake
put out a twit longer in which he
alleged that zack was not the victim and
that
zack had initiated oral sex with nairo
while nairo was asleep
tamim also implicated another pro smash
player ezra samsora morris saying that
samsora and zach collaborated to bring
nairo down
something that samsora denies to this
day anyway back to nairo on october 28th
naima released a statement with
his side of the events that zachaletch
occurred nairo begins by saying that
zack's allegations are completely false
and follows it up by saying that he only
apologized because he was panicked and
emotional
nairo continues on by saying that he was
never in a relationship with zack
and follows that up by detailing his
side of the events on the night in
question
nairo states that on april 15 2017 he
was approached by captain zack and a
friend
who asked nairo if they could stay in
his hotel room for the weekend of ceo
dreamland
a smash tournament in florida nairo
alleges that he reluctantly agreed to
let zak and his friends stay with him
because he believed he was their last
option then naira writes this we slept
in our own separate beds but i woke up
to zach molesting me
i freaked out terrified but my body
froze up and he forcefully performed
oral sex on me
i yelled at him to stop but he refused
and he only stopped once i managed to
push him off me
i was so shaken up by everything what he
just did
his betrayal of my trust in letting him
stay that i just shut down
nairo alleges that the next day zach
attempted to initiate sexual contact
again
and that after nairo refused zack
allegedly threatened to go public with
the information that the two had sex
and then blackmailed nairo into letting
zack perform oral sex on him nairo
alleges that the next month
at another smash tournament zak
attempted to blackmail nairo again
and after the two spoke zack apologized
and agreed to never speak about what
happened ever again
nairo also alleges that in may 2019 the
two spoke again
and zach offered to quote take the
bullet if the truth ever came out
nairo then alleges that in august 2019
zack asked him for money when his
sponsor polar ace dropped him following
the allegations about him blackmailing
ally came out
nairo says that he was reluctant to send
over the funds but
nairo also says that after he saw how
zack had blackmailed ally
he agreed to send over a total of 2 625
between august 2019 and february 2020.
nairo notes that zach himself has since
confessed that the hush money
allegations were false but
zack hasn't publicly admitted that
himself to meme released a twit longer
in september in which he shares
screenshots of what appears to be a
discord conversation he had had
with zack in which zac shares
screenshots of a text conversation he
appears to have had with nairo of him
asking for money hush money is not
mentioned in any of these screenshots
nairo ends his statement by accusing
zack of rape and blackmail
and says that while he feels his ousting
from the competitive smash scene is
unjust
he doesn't want to re-enter the
community right now so that's
a lot of heavy stuff zack has not
responded publicly since nairo's
statement
and nairo also says that he has a
30-page document including
evidence to support his case but he
didn't share that document publicly
notably some members of the smash
community have seen the document
and say that they believe naira's
allegations but to be clear
these are all just allegations we have
not seen any evidence from either side
yet so
all we have to go on is zach's word
versus nairo's
nairo zach and many others who are
accused of sexual misconduct have been
banned by several tournament organizers
and it's unclear given these events if
those bans are being reconsidered or
even if they should be but the fact that
the allegations of july are still
shifting
is proof that the smash community can't
just rest and hope that all the
predators magically disappeared because
some people were brave enough to come
forward with accusations
this isn't to say that people made false
accusations i do not want to suggest
that at all
it's just that the situation is still
fluid but the whole situation really
begs the question
what happens when smash inevitably
returns i reached out to a handful of
tournament organizers with questions
about
how they're planning on keeping the
community safe when in-person
tournaments resume
unfortunately i didn't receive any
responses by the time this video was out
for publication
which means all i can really do right
now is speculate last time we did a
video about this i asked why there were
so many allegations in the smash scene
this time i want to ask what happens
next the situation is going to keep
evolving
obviously anybody who's been found
guilty should be banned but the fact
matter is there are already some players
who've been banned by certain
tournaments who are already playing in
others
take captain zack for example we have no
hard evidence to suggest that zach was
engaged in sexual misconduct
only testimony but zack has admitted to
blackmailing ally and engaging in
bracket manipulation
something that got him banned from
several major smash tournaments
however zack was recently spotted
playing in small local tournaments in
louisiana under a new tag
obviously this means that zack is not
banned in louisiana and continues to
play there if he likes
but it goes to show how someone who has
been banned or accused of sexual
misconduct
can continue to be a part of the
community and potentially harm more
people
even after they've been banned again i
am not saying that zack 100
will abuse someone and i am not saying
that he 100 abused someone
all i am saying is that he is an example
of a player who is clearly banned
who is still able to participate in the
community and that fact
concerns me what happens when smash
tournaments return on
mass and each tournament organizer in
every state has their own unique
ban list i understand this match is
grassroots that there's no global body
deciding who is and isn't allowed in the
convention centers of north america
but i don't think that makes the end
result palatable do you institute age
minimums for tournaments do you make
people come with a chaperone
do you get rid of after parties even
though that would mean that people just
have their after-parties in their own
hotel rooms i don't have the answer
right now
look i love smash i think that it's a
community full of wonderful people who
do not deserve to play in the same space
as creeps and
people defending those creeps i don't
know what tournament organizers are
doing behind the scenes to protect the
community from predators
i just only hope that they're doing
[Music]
something
[Music]
you